this is maria pia cascello's second
covet jab
a short visit with long-reaching effects
we were afraid we couldn't go shopping i
want all of italy to be vaccinated so we
can get back to normal
all of italy not just yet but nearly all
the adults on iskia and island off
naples coast
are on their way to being fully
vaccinated by the end of june
this past weekend local officials
proclaimed the campaign a success
seventy-five percent of adults on iskia
and a smaller neighboring island
have had their first dose it's part of a
pilot program
to inoculate isolated populations
against covet 19.
islands are difficult areas to deliver
immediate medical care
although iskia has a hospital with 60
beds we took these steps because we
can't risk turning it entirely into a
covered ward
where we won't be able to care for all
the other sick patients
nineteen-year-old alecia borreli
wouldn't have got a vaccine for several
months on the mainland
she's now vaccinated as are her parents
the family is returning to activities
that were restricted for months
for those of us who live on islands near
the water taking away the sea was like
killing us being vaccinated
now is like a dream
a dream many on the island want to share
with the outside world
iskia like much of italy relies on
tourism
2020 was the worst year for tourism here
in decades and officials are hoping a
vaccinated population along with
transparent waters
and sun speckled beaches are going to
convince people to come here
because it's safe bookings for this
summer across iskia are 65 percent below
pre-pandemic levels hotel association
president luka dambra
explains why he thinks isukia needs to
fast-track vaccinations
there are two main reasons actually
which will put on the same level once
of course it's for the safeness of our
citizen on iskia
and of course of our clients they are
coming and on the other side
is because the economy starts again
iskia
leaves about tourism and it's important
for us to
turn back at the normality as we well
any return to normality though will
require the outside world
to catch up to this outcrop of immunity
adam marini al jazeera on the italian
island of viskaya